안녕하세요 오늘은 여러분들이
서울시에서 반드시 주목해야 될 지역을
설명드리도록 하겠습니다네 우선 첫
번째로 서울시에서 가장 핫한 빌딩
투자 지역 탑 5를 고르자면 첫
번째로 강남 그다음에 성동 용산 마포
서초를 좀 꼽을 수 있습니다 근데
여기서 여의도는 왜 빠졌어 하실 텐데
여의도는 사실 투자할 만한 그런 작은
빌딩들이 많이 없어요 대부분 다 이제
대형 빌딩들이 좀 많이 있다 보니까
여러분들이 실질적으로 여의도의 단독
건물을 투자하기에는 사실 쉽지
않습니다 우선 첫 번째로 강남을 좀
정했는데 강남구가 사실 서울 지금
25개 구 중에 거래량이 제일
많습니다 그 정도로 많은 사람들이
투자를 하고 있고 강남구 내에서도
동마다 거래량이 좀 많이 차이가나요
제가 말씀드리는 강남구는 전체 다
강남구가 아니라 뭐 예를 들어서
노현동 신사동 청담동 삼성동 대치동
역삼동요 정도만 보시면 될 거 같아요
그래서 그 정도 더이 제일 거래량이
많고 성동구는 성동구를 다 포함하는게
아니라 여러분들 잘 아시겠지만
성수동이 1가 성수동 2가 두 가지
동만 보시면 될 거 같습니다 그 두
개동이 제일 핫하고 그리고 용상 같은
경우에는 최근에 이제 거래되는 거
보면은 뭐 이태원 동의 거래량이 좀
많아졌고 그리고 한남동도서관
이이나 뭐 신용산역 1대 이쪽에
거래량이 좀 많이 늘어났습니다 특히
여러분들이 여기 한남동 쪽을 좀
유심히 보셨으면 좋을 거 같습니다
제가 봤을 땐 가장 핫한 거 같고
마포고 같은 경우에는 마포구가 다
좋은게 아니라 거래량이 그래도 많은
데는 이제 홍대 입구역 근처 그까
이제 뭐 서교동 이라든지 동교동
이라든지 합정동 이런 동네가 그
마포구에서 거래량이 제일 많습니다
그래서 그쪽 지역을 좀 유심히 보시면
좋을 거 같고 그 마지막으로 서초구
같은 경우에는
서초동이정재
뭐 교대 역이라는 그쪽 지역을 다
포함하는 거예요 그래서 그렇다 보니까
그쪽 거래량이 좀 높은 편이고 그리고
두 번째로 이제 방배동 거래량도 좀
많이 높습니다 그래서 다른 구와
비교해서 거래량이 좀 많다라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 그리고 또 많은
사람들이 요즘에 성수동 핫하잖아요
그러다 보니까 강 남구 빌딩이 좋아요
성수동 빌딩이 좋아요 질문을 워낙
많이 받습니다 그래서 그거를 좀 제
개인적인 생각으로 좀 정리해 드리자면
강남구도 동마다 차이가 있다 그래서
뭐 예를 들어서 신사동이 뭐 청담
동이다 제가 말하는 신사 청담은
한강변 바로 앞에 그니까 이제 앞구정
현대 바로 앞에 있는 신사나 청담이
하면 제가 봤을 때는 성수동 다 더
투자 가치가 높다라고 생각을 합니다
근데 반대로 강남구 내에서도 좀
외곽에 있거나 역에 안 접해 있거나
아니면 좀 남쪽에 있거나 그런
경우에는 오히려 성수동이 더 좋을 수
있어요 근데 성수동 좀 세부적으로
들어가 봐야 돼요 예를 들어서 뭐
연무장길 그 거기 일 때는 워낙 좋죠
근데 예를 들어서 뭐 성수에서 조금
빠지는 곳이라든지 아니면 북 성수에
있다라는 북 성수도 좋아지고 있긴
하지만 그 상대적으로는 좀 성수
내에서도 갈리는 경우가 많거든요
그래서 여러분들이 그냥 지역별로
이렇게 바로 나누는게 아니라 내가 뭐
100억대 건물을 산다라고 하면
강남에서는 어떤 동 위주로 보고 성수
같은 경우에는 어떤 블록을 볼 건지를
정해 놓고 투자를 해야지 그냥 아
나는 뭐 성수 안 하고 강남만 살
거야 아 아니 나는 강남 안 사고
성수만 살 거야 이렇게 하실 필요는
없습니다 일단 좀 정리해 보자면
강남이다 성수다 이렇게 할게 아니라
더 세부적으로 보셔야 됩니다
세부적으로 동을 더 깊숙히 들어가고
더 세부적으로 들어가면 도로를
기준으로 보셔야 돼요 그렇게 분리할
때도 그런 부분을 기억하셨으면 좋겠고
그리고 저는 강남구에 앞구정 현대
맞은편에 있는 건물들 있잖아요 그걸
제가 왜 좋게 보냐며 어찌됐든 최근에
그 신현대 통과 됐잖아요 그래가지고
좀 재건축 속도가 되게 빨라졌는데
아마 그게 지어지면 100억이 아니라
진짜 몇백억대 아파트들이 많이 생겨날
거예요 그런 아파트들 때문에 가격이
덩달아서 오를 겁니다 그래서 그게
만약에 실제로 그렇게 매각이 되거나
아니면 고액 전세로 들어올 경우에는
그렇게 만약에 팔았던 사람들이 대부분
다 이제 거기 맞은 편의 건물들을
많이 사거든요 그리고 이제 거기
거주하시는 분들이 실제로 그 앞에
있는 빌딩들을 많이 매입해요 그러다
보니까 그게 나중에 이제 재건축이
되고 진짜 초고가 아파트가 되면은
지금 거기 1일대 있는 부동산들은 다
같이 오를 가능성이 저는 매우
크다라고 생각을 합니다 그리고 특히
강남구 내에서 삼성역 같은 경우에는
뭐 최근에 뭐 업비트도 매입하고 뭐
비선도 매입했던 것처럼 돈번 기업들이
그쪽으로 좀 많이 매입을 할 거
같아요 그걸로 통해서 같이 덩달아서
가격이 오르거나 현대차 부지 뭐
gbc 이제 개발하고 나서 그거와
관련된 업체라는 그리고 거기 상주
인원이 엄청 많거든 진짜 몇십만
명이든 그래서 그 정도로 많은
인구들이 어차피 들어오기 때문에 그쪽
삼성역 1대 때도 천지 개벽할 거라고
저는 생각을 하고 부동산 중계하시는
분들끼리 뭐 이런 얘기도 해요 나
강남에 사옥 있다가 아니라 더
깊숙하게 들어가서 난 삼성역의 사옥
있다라고 얘기할 정도로 그렇게
삼성역이 좀 많이 개발될 거라고 저는
예상을 합니다네 그리고 성수동이 또
좋은 이유 중에 하나가 용도 지역이
중공업 지역이거든요 그래서 용적률이
400% 아지 적용을 받기 때문에
만약에 2종이고 치면은 용적률을 거의
두 배 받을 수 있습니다 토지
활용도가 워낙 좋기 때문에 그런 점
때문에 성수동이 좀 많이 인기를
얻는게 아닌가 이렇게 생각을 하고
있습니다 그래서 뭐 기업 입장에서는
땅의 활용도가 너무 좋기 때문에 거기
사옥을 만들기가 너무 좋거든요 그래서
그런 부분 때문에 좀 성수동에 많이
투자를 하고 있지 않나 이렇게 생각을
합니다 그래서 좀 정리해 보면
강남이나 성수 쪽에도 워낙 동별로
아니면 도로별 양극화가 되게 심하기
때문에 지역별로 볼게 아니라
세부적으로 그 동 그 길 위주로 좀
이렇게 세부적으로 보셔야 되는 부분이
있습니다 그래서 마지막으로 여러분들이
미래 가치가 가장 높은 지역
어디야라고 하면 딱 한 문장으로
정리할 수 있을 것 같아요 부자들이
많이 사는 동네에 투자하시면 됩니다
그래서 2024년 한국 부자 보고서를
보자면 거기에 이제 한국에서 서울시의
대부분 부자들이 많이 거주를 하고
있습니다 그리고 그중에 대부분 다
강남 3구에 거주하고 있어요 그리고
최근에 저희가 작년에 빌딩 매입한
사람들의 등기 사항 전부 증 명상을
다 떼서 봤는데 거기도 보면은
228명 중에 약 절반 이상이 다
강남구 거주자입니다 그래서 2만은
뭐냐면 부자들은 다른 동네 투자를 잘
안 해요 뭐 여러분들이 예를 들어서
내가 만약에 뭐 강남에 어디에 살고
있다라고 하면 사실 서울시 외곽 뭐
지리도 잘 모를 뿐더러 갑자기 다른
지역에 투자하지 않거든요 그래서 그
돈 번 사람들이 자기가 잘 알고 있는
지역 대부분 다 투자합니다 막 이런
거 많잖아요 갑자기이 지역이 뜬다더니
지역이 여기 들어오고 막 근처
상권들이 엄청 좋아진다더니 굉장히
노후화된 데를 투자하는 경우가 많은데
그럴 경우에 되게 리스크가 되게
큽니다 그 지역이 진짜 통 채로
개발되지 않은 이상 그 지역에 받아줄
사람이 없거든요 제가 앞서
설명드렸지만 용산 같은 경우에도 사실
한남동에 이런 고급 주거가 많잖아요
뭐 한남 더이라 그지 나이원 이라든지
뭐 유엔 빌리지라는 요런 고급 주택이
많기 때문에 거기 사는 사람들은 거기
앞에
투자하거나 이라든지 아서포든지
갤러리아 포레라 그지 이런 고급
아파트들이 많잖아요 근데 그 사람들이
대부분 다 성수동
투자하거나 그러실 거예요 지금 영상을
보시는 분들도 내가 제일 잘하는 지역
투자 하는 경우 많거든요 그렇다
보니까 돈이 몰리는 곳에 투자를
여러분들이 하셔야 돼요 그래야지
나중에 받아줄 사람도 많습니다 그리고
부자들이 지금 데이터 보면은 작년에도
늘었어요 그 지금 경기가 매우 안
좋긴 하지만 부자들은 계속 늘고
있습니다 그리고 최근에 신흥 부자들이
좀 많이 늘어나고 있어요 뭐 예를
들어서 뭐 코인 부자라는 미국
주식으로 돈 버신 분들이라는이 분들이
다 어디에 투자하겠습니다 다 좋은데
사고 싶어 하거든요 다 트로피 성격의
부동산을 사려고 하거든요 그러다
보니까 앞으로 이런 양 극한은 제가
봤을 때 더 심해질 것 같습니다 그
정리를 해보면 부자들이 많이 사는
동네에 투자를 해야지 투자 실패
확률을 줄일 수 있다 이게 딱 한
문장으로 정리가 됩니다 제가 앞서
설명드렸던 투자 가치가 있는 지역도
다 그런 비싼 아파트라는 이런게 많은
지역이에요 그 사람들이 다른데 투자
안 합니다 본인 동네 인근 잘 아는
지역 투자하기 때문에 한국 경제
상황도 안 좋고 지금 초고령화 사회고
지금 일본을 보더라도 김자하 이런
주요 지역은 부동산 가격이 계속
오르잖아요 여러분들이 앞으로 부동산
투자를 한다라고 하면 지금 부자들이
많이 사는지요 부자들이 좋아할 만한
부동산을 투자를 해야지 실패 확률을
줄일 수 있다라고 저는 강력하게
생각을 합니다 그래서 여러분들이이
부분을 기억하셨다가 앞으로 투자
계획을 세우시면 좋을 것 같습니다
빌딩은 역시 산악
[음악]
h